yeah I mean 105 initially wanna see what
we see Nancy Warrington did you catch
that this guy makes more in one day than
a doctor makes in a month and he's a
taxi driver well he's actually a trained
engineer but engineers make even less
than doctors welcome to the Cuban
economy right after the socialist
revolution in 1959 Fidel Castro's
government seized almost all private
businesses in land you won't have to
worry about next year the state will do
your planning from now on every
restaurant factory hospital and home was
property of the government the state set
prices for everything and decided how
much people got paid the private sector
disappeared overnight the world these
men live in desperately needs economic
reforms you can see the result of this
if you go looking for food in Havana
today when I showed up it was pretty
excited to see what Street food was on
offer but all I could find was this just
this ham sandwiches everywhere here's a
typical scene in the Cuban eatery too
many employees in an empty establishment
with empty shelves they're just waiting
for food deliveries from the government
and putting in their eight hours so that
they can go home they get paid the same
whether they sell one plate of food or
fifty this model just doesn't work
Cuba survived for many years with
subsidies from the Soviet Union but
since its collapse the economy has been
getting worse every year
this lady is showing me her government
ration card that she's kept for decades
Cubans use these cards to go to the
storage houses to get their monthly
rations let's take the envelope Anthea
go grab this one
Rocketman me I have only one hand in the
lava needed an intake well Evalia
on menopause you stay clicking on make
sure our process on a uniform on the
government realized this was becoming a
problem in the 90s and started giving
out private licenses fueling a small but
growing private sector I stumbled upon a
private restaurant in Havana and it was
a totally different experience than the
public ones there was actually movement
and good service the owners had to sell
good food if they wanted to stay in
business which brings me back to the
taxi driver and the doctor the reason
why taxi drivers make so much more than
doctors is because they have private
licenses
the salaries are not set by the state
and they can charge tourists high prices
I paid $25 to get from the airport into
Havana and in that 30 minutes this
driver made more than an average monthly
salary of a Cuban which is $20 what
you're releasing sample dr. song there's
a video in the alley
you know I'm sequin the festival also
said yeah one of the problems with this
is that you get highly trained workers
leaving their trade to go do remedial
work in the private sector this guy's an
engineer but he's cooking in a private
restaurant
these guys are accountants by trade but
are making a killing driving around
tourists on taxi bikes this woman is a
nurse but she hasn't worked in a
hospital in years this guy is an
electrical engineer but he opened up a
barber shop in his house and makes 10
times more than he would in his field of
study imagine trying to live on the
Cuban average salary of $20 per month
when you ask them how they do it they
all have the same response Oh
wherever okay it's a nanny
okay see not noble just beneath the
surface in Cuba is a bustling informal
market where Cubans make an additional
income on top of their official salary
just to survive so brave oedema Gracia
si si Murtagh Carosa Mercado
subterranean cuando yo bajo mi car say
crews o la calle are para comprar el
periódico ya Stojko metiendo el primer
Torito de Receptus EO for cases a or
Nancy ANOVA table and en dome el
periodico Molotov entiendo sobre pricey
yeah DNA have reg lado esto con con la
persona que trabaja aquí de guadalupe
areola Kozelek when de mooch nto
associate black markets with dangerous
activities but in Cuba people sell
illegal popsicles or newspapers not to
get rich but just to survive but things
are slowly changing since Fidel's
brother Raul took over in 2008 the
number of private licenses has increased
significantly every year and 20% of the
economy is not private but still most
Cubans are jaded by the decades they've
had to use illegal creativity just to
survive a little advice the nice things
about food [ __ ] we're done
you